what happened absolutely nothing i don't
know i just i just showed up and i don't
know just i don't even know the guy to
be honest with you not so fast conor
mcgregor it appears something did happen
when the professional fighter crossed
paths with rapper machine gun kelly on
the 2021 vmas red carpet on sunday night
watch out for mcgregor
in fact rapper jaw rule saw the whole
thing and spilled it all to e.t i tell
you joe rule my head is spinning the
vmas there and say this is what the vmas
are all about man everybody's here we're
having a good time this is this is big
night for the celebrities and the stars
so we out it truly is i mean you came
over here the demilia family was their
machine gun kelly megan megan fox i just
can't i heard there was a fight with
machine gun and and and and uh conor
mcgregor just over there about two
minutes ago so we were already off to a
good start oh you're telling no that's
what that's what i heard over there
that's uh you know i'm just i'm just
relaying the messages
according to an eyewitness conor
mcgregor and mgk quote exchanged some
words and then conor lunged at mgk the
rapper and megan left the carpet and
threatened not to do picks but then they
returned once conor left
megan
you'll always dress the part how did you
coordinate these outfits this evening
the machine gun take the lead and then
megan you were like ah he was like
you're going to be naked tonight and i
was like whatever you say
daddy whatever daddy says are you proud
of him very proud he's the most talented
boy in the world
and then you're pretty oh
pretty talented too seeing you and
bloody valentine are you guys going to
collaborate more when it comes to your
music videos in the future
i mean yeah he's not allowed to have
other hoes in his music video
it's the queen or no one
megan you guys look awesome we'll be
back oh
i don't know if this is family friendly
y'all
so once we saw connor backstage at the
vmas we had to ask him about this wild
confrontation i heard about the scuffle
you have with machine gun kelly on the
carpet no school
no i don't know the man i don't know the
man he's obviously him and megan to be
at the at the fight so what happened
absolutely nothing i don't know i just i
just showed up and i don't know just i
don't even know the guy to be honest
with you just rumors
just for real there's nothing happening
with me i only fight real fighters
people that actually fight you know i
mean i certainly don't fight little
vanilla boy rappers you know i don't
even know the guy i don't know anything
about him except that he's making folks
we were chatting earlier on the carpet
and it was like a game of telephone out
there he was bringing me the news that
there was a little scuffle between
machine gun kelly
and it was all the talk honey so oh so i
was right you oh
i had the teeth
and he was like let me just sip this
chip
had to pick you out on
it was hot